[موسيقى]
تحت علم الدولة الروسية
موكل المجد وراية النصر
أفضل محارب
الطائرات ، وكذلك
تربية المرح الأساسية
الأحداث في سانت بطرسبرغ
ومن هنا جاء الشباب المتدرب ورثة الأميرال
لازاريف وأوشاكوف هما ألوان التركية
البلطيق كاريليان
لينينغراد ، كانت هذه البداية
تغيير جذري في معركة لينينغراد
الرسائل والدفاع الجوي
ديميتريس أنتم متخصصون
[موسيقى]
قوات الاتحاد الروسي والتغوط
اواز باتريوت سيارة الدفع الرباعي
على الطرق الوعرة قبل أن تنفجر
مقر الجسور
أحدث درع من خطط العرض
جنود وضباط فترة ما بعد الحرب
كتائب نفذت بإيثار
خط الصيد الدولي وقذائف الهاون
البطاريات
قاذفات صواريخ مركبة قتال مشاة
BMP-3
الموجهة للأجهزة تختبئ هناك
حيث يشعر 6 خزان منفصل
المشاركة في العرض الجوي
الجندي لينينغرادسكوي
لافتة حمراء
[موسيقى]
يكون محور طائرات الهليكوبتر mi-26 التالية
أربعة مساعدين مخلصين